to present the Irving G Thalberg
Memorial Award which is voted by the
Academy Board of Governors for
consistently high quality of motion
picture production here is the
oscar-winning director of the French
Connection William Friedkin
the Thalberg award has been given only
19 times since it was established it
honors the memory of a great motion
picture producer Irving G Thalberg
tonight we honor the 20th recipient of
that award for his career record of
filmmaking and what a record like most
of my generation I was raised on his
films Little Caesar five star final I'm
a fugitive from a chain gang tugboat
Annie Anthony adverse Waterloo Bridge
blossoms in the dust
random harvest Madame Curie
Quo Vadis and oh yes The Wizard of Oz
and that's only because I've been told
to keep it short
75 films bear his name permit me a
personal assessment almost more than any
other this producer director identifies
not only with the writers the stars and
the technicians of his films he
identifies totally with the audience
whatever the current style in personal
cinema you'll seek it in vain in his
pictures he makes movies about people
you root for that's all
and that's why audiences have adored his
pictures throughout the world ladies and
gentlemen the recipient of the Irving G
Thalberg award mr. Mervyn Leroy
on behalf of the Academy your friends
and the people to whom you've given so
many good scenes with so much feeling
here's a little something in return
thank you very very much well it
certainly is thrilling for me and it's
nice to get the Irving Thalberg award
handed to me I'm another director and a
good one too
I I was a very dear dear friend of
Irving Thalberg and it was a shame that
a man like Irving Thalberg had to had a
passed away at 37 years old he was a
genius he had great heart great feeling
great imagination after a preview that
should go to perving would set up with
you upstairs at metro and he'd say I
know what's what's good about the
picture tell me what's wrong about the
picture and Irving never made a
criticism about a movie unless he
couldn't prove it that's the kind of a
man he was and this means so much to me
that I can't tell you he was quite a guy
I loved him he was very close to me I
wish we had more rings all Berg's around
today but they're around and they'll
come out believe me I want to thank the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences for giving me this beautiful
award voting it for me
believing in me because they've done so
much for the world and tonight I think
they've done more for the world than
ever by showing what Hollywood does and
running all of these beautiful acts and
beautiful scenes on Telstar which I am a
stockholder
Tiggy we were going on some films
tonight but they're a little late and
I'm a little late and I'm a little
nervous I want to thank you all and I
love you all and this means so much to
me thank you